on august 26th three wishes will send  her on an adventure of a lifetime make a  wish only by granting you your heart's  desire i earned my release  he'll be staying for a while hello hello  critics are saying george miller's first  movie since mad max fury road is a wish  come true this is a story of a woman and  she encounters a genie the problem is  she knows that all stories about wishing  are cautionary tales i'm beginning to  think i'm in the presence of a trickster  it's aladdin for adults  a different kind of blockbuster  eventually she does make a wish and it  surprises both of them find the biggest  screen possible to truly absorb this  beautiful film would you like this  little albert einstein put him back is  that your wish no it's your obligation  three thousand years of longing rated r  playing only in movie theaters august  26th  tickets on sale now  you